ich ärgere mich schon lange und immer
wieder und heute aktuell wie wir das
berufsbild kindern in schulen und in
büchern vermitteln ich war heute aktuell
in einer buchhandlung oder zu zweit in
berlin und habe mir mal kinderbücher
angeguckt wenn ich mal groß werde
so dann alles klassisch alles
traditionell feuerwehrmann
polizist er kommt schon mal fast was
progressives sie doch gleich ganz anders
aus modedesignerin und da habe ich ein
buch entdeckt mein album vom ersten
schultag und das heißt der ernst des
lebens beginnt
und ich sehe das ganz anders es gibt
nämlich einen beruf der spaß macht bei
dem man am meisten lernt und das ist der
job das berufsbild von gründerinnen und
gründern und in all diesen büchern
nichts über erfinderin erfinder
innovation dabei brauchen wir die
innovation die erfindungen dass unsere
welt besser wird dass es digitaler wird
die sünder wird
nachhaltiger wird mehr die umwelt
beachtet wird und kinder sind die
fantasievollsten die ideenreichsten
menschen und die kreativsten die müssen
wir ganz früh fördern und darüber ist
nicht zu finden und das habe ich gemerkt
es gibt keine bücher darüber und
deswegen habe ich mit meinem co autor
axel teubert ein buch geschrieben wir
haben ein kindergerechtes
gründungs buch geschrieben ist also das
erste
unternehmerische buch für kinder und der
titel ist die start up ging und ich
möchte dass wir mehr gründerin bekommen
mehr gründer und deswegen möchte ich
dass wir alle zusammen unsere kinder
frühzeitig motivieren und für diesen
faszinierenden beruf gewinnen
ich habe ja noch keine kinder kam ich
immer noch gut auf an meine kindheit
erinnern und zum beispiel wir durften
oder sollten nicht mit baby born spielen
weil mein vater und auch meine mutter
nicht das gefühl hat dass es sinnvoll
ist dass ich schon mit vier jahren die
mutter mine zu hause und auch ich würde
auch heute sagen das war gar nicht so
schlecht ich finde aber dass mit den
büchern m ganz spannend und auf einem
auch sehr wichtig es gibt ja auch bücher
diese nur für jungs geschrieben und nur
für mädchen geschrieben das ist dort
auch immer noch sehr auseinander nur die
frage die ich mir stelle ist mit dem
buch wenn das kind das dann liest wie
kann man denn dann weiter machen und die
fähigkeiten auch weiter ausbauen ich
finde ist vor allem wichtig dass die
jungen menschen die kinder und
jugendliche entdecken neben den
klassischen berufen die ja in der regel
eine angestellten welt darstellen eine
arbeitnehmer rolle dass es eben diese
faszination der selbstständigkeit des
unternehmertums des gründen ob das ein
kleiner handwerksbetrieb ist ob das der
friseursalon dass es eben diese
berufswelt auch gibt und das wollte ich
ändern das kommt in kinderbüchern bisher
nicht vor das teile die diagnose ich
teile ihre diagnose und ich glaube es
hängt damit zusammen dass
unternehmer bei uns in der
öffentlichkeit generell ein viel
schlechteres image haben schadet
verdienen
sind leute die viel zu viel verdienen
und aufgeregt sind raffgierig sind
schmarotzer hat und so weiter also wir
haben mal beobachtet hat wie viel diese
leute so arbeiten der
korrigiert die diese auffassung aber das
ist das ist der widerschein des
unternehmertums wie einem in der
öffentlichkeit oft begegnet dass das
aber nicht der realität entspricht also
dass das nicht dem entspricht was die
leute auf der straße viele von ihnen
jedenfalls denken zeigt der erfolg
dieser fernseh show in der sie setzen
können die ja unheimlich
eingeschlagen hat und die von nichts
anderem handelt als von leuten eine gute
idee haben und eine leidenschaft für
diese idee haben und dann im reich
werden einige von ihnen natürlich nicht
alle aber einige von ihnen schaffen das
ist dann eben und dieser dieser gedanke
ich erfinde etwas oder ich stelle etwas
auf die beine was die leute brauchen was
im ideal für ihr leben besser macht oder
irgendetwas in eine ihnen ein bedürfnis
erfüllt
etwas wunderbares eigentlich das wird
bei uns nicht genug gewürdigt
man nimmt den rücken übel dass sie dafür
dann im extremfall viel geld bekommen
während man leuten die sagen wir mal
eine politische karriere machen und ich
verdiene natürlich nicht so viel wie ein
erfolgreicher unternehmer aber man nimmt
ihnen das auch nicht so übel dass sie
mehr verdienen als der durchschnitt sie
haben lange arbeitstag ja diesen langen
arbeitstag hat ein unternehmer aber auch
und er muss natürlich auch um erfolg zu
haben auf dieses und jenes verzichtet
das ist ja auch ein preis den man dem
mars in der startup welt kenne ich in
unserem portfolio wir sind 130 start-ups
beteiligt kein gründungsteam wo die
gesagt haben wir haben gegründet um
reich zu werden die wollen ein problem
lösen die wollen sparsam die wollen ein
bisschen die welt verändern und 9 von
startups es kann man rechnen wie früher
beginnt das scheitern ja dh die haben
alles geld was sie am anfang selbst
reingesteckt haben von der oma geliehen
was die vorzeitiges erbe sie haben drei
lebensjahren verschenkt das ist ja auch
ein chance risiko profil und ich möchte
dass wir eben mit kindern auch über
risiken rät über rückschläge selbst
bayern münchen gewinnt nicht jedes spiel
wir müssen eben niederlagen dass man das
wieder aufstehen und darüber handelt
dieses buch
einen sicheren job aufgegeben hier im
springer-verlag ich war chefredakteur
der welt bin ich in die schweiz
zurückgekommen habe ich mit millionen
verschuldet meine firma zu übernehmen
und ich bin aber leider etwas später ins
unternehmerische eingestiegen wie sie
und ich teile ihre analyse und hätten
sie es gelesen
nicht dies ist titanische
selbstvertrauen das sie auch sagen aber
ich sage ihnen sie haben recht der
unternehmen das unternehmerische denken
das ist etwas elementares in unserer
kultur ich mein deutschland ist als
österreich wir sind durch diese
unternehmen kmu kleine und mittlere
unternehmen das sind auch startups sind
wir groß geworden und ich möchte das
noch unterstreichen aus der harald
martenstein gesagt wir haben die medien
eine riesige verantwortung weil die
medien sind für mich viel zu politik
hörig die die die rennen da den schleier
den politikern in trier und die
unternehmer die werden immer noch
kritisch fertig gemacht auch mit diesen
eid kultur und man müsste viel mehr
druck auf die politik machen dass die
politik eine unternehmerfreundliche
politik macht das heißt die belastungen
zurücknimmt dass man die unternehmen die
bürger entlastet damit der risiko geist
belohnt wird wobei nichts gegen den
beruf des polizisten aus ich wäre froh
wenn wir brauchen welche lizenzen sind
auch gut das ist auch ein toller job du
kannst ja auch zuerst polizist werden
und demnach unternehmer ich wollte
gleich eingestellt wurden bleiben wir
ganz kurz da würde ich gerne jan fragen
bleiben wir ganz kurz bei dem punkt wie
der unternehmer in den medien
dargestellt wird und ein punkt ist ja
der dass viele journalisten eher links
denn da gibt es ja auch studien zu
letzte befragung ist schon ein paar
jahre her aber da hat man ganz klar
gesehen der linksruck den gibt es schon
im journalismus wie würdest du es
einschätzen warum der unternehmer aber
das mit dem tatort stimmt wirklich
verletzt auch wieder sehr erschrocken
über eine folge tatort als wieder der
unternehmer der raffgierige war und der
mörder war vielleicht auch da sind wir
uns in dieser runde hier ziemlich einig
das ist in der tat etwas und roger
köppel hat sie auch grad noch mal gesagt
das geht eigentlich vom kopf runter bis
er so von von der von der politik vom
bundeskanzler oder der bundeskanzlerin
runter dann bis in die schulen also wir
fangen beim steuersystem an wenn wir uns
die debatte von letzter woche noch
einmal vor augen führen als es darum
ging ja wie entlasten wir eigentlich und
wie entlasten wir da war am ende immer
die frage der suv fahrer und der
porsche-fahrer die dürften also nicht
entlastet werden und jetzt können wir
davon ausgehen vielleicht ist der
porsche fahrer eher jemand der ein
bisschen mehr verdient hat oder auch der
suv fahrer aus welchen gründen auch
immer möglicherweise sind auch
unternehmer darunter und automatisch
schwimmt ja dann hier schon mit in genau
diesen aussagen erstmalig das für teil
rassistisch weil es gegen eine gewisse
gruppe geht und diskriminieren so
gespalten genau hier wird nicht
zusammengeführt hier wird gespalten also
von respekt kann man da gar nicht reden
auch wenn die partei des bundeskanzlers
in der von respekt im wahlkampf
gesprochen hat also hier wurde gespielt
und ganz klar
hin gespalten zu menschen die
möglicherweise ein bisschen mehr
verdienen also die sind per se schon mal
da und jetzt sagen sie vielen gründern
und das ist total ehren wird geht es gar
nicht ums geldverdienen klar auch in den
hinterkopf werden es geklappt und sie
haben nicht verdient hat aber so und das
ist ja schon wichtig zu wissen wie ihr
seht ihr ein deutschland
interessanterweise dass es ganz ganz
viele junge leute auch geht die sich zum
beispiel nichts sehnlicher wünschen als
beim staat angestellt zu sein da
verdient man in deutschland zum teil
extrem muss man sagen und man hat nach
sicheren job dann kein reef 950 und man
muss sich freilich beleidigen lassen
dass man wenn man mit dem porsche
beispielsweise vorgefahren kommt und im
suv gleich die ganzen finger im gesicht
hat du bist aber offenbar jemand
erreichen du bist eigentlich b du hast
eigentlich irgendwie gemauschelt und
irgendwas falsch gemacht und um auf
diese frage zurückzukommen wir haben ein
gravierendes problem in deutschland ein
gravierendes problem denn am ende wissen
wir auch dass es die unternehmer sind
die die jobs schaffen ja haben bei
risiko ich habe das risiko und
verantwortung für andere menschen zu
übernehmen das ist endlich schaffen die
arbeitsplätze ich war am freitag an der
polnischen grenze habe das hotel wichtig
und besucht wo das wir angemietet haben
um ukrainische
flüchtlingsfamilien meist mütter mit
kindern jüngst ist vier wochen die
älteste frau aus 80 jahre besucht haben
und neben der großen dankbarkeit was
arbeiterwohlfahrt rote kreuz die stadt
die mitarbeiterin alle leisten über 1
schütteln den kopf die digitalisierung
die sind in der ukraine gewohnt dass sie
die digitale identität
haben erklärt klack klack ist der pass
verlängert jetzt stehen die da um das
werden listen ausgefüllt abgeheftet
kopiert die wollen die sprache lernen
sie wollen arbeiten aber das erstens
dauert mindestens drei wochen bis sie
irgendwie sprachunterricht bekommen und
damit jetzt ich für dieses buch die
werbung nicht falsch verstehen haben co
autor und ich entschieden alle autoren
erlöse die wir pro buch bekommen werden
wir haben die uno für die ukraine
flüchtlingshilfe spenden das also ich
will etwas verändern und wollte mich
hier nicht bereichern ich hoffe dass wir
vielleicht in ein paar jahren in höhe
der löwen mal ein gründungsteam haben
die gesagt haben weil wir das buch
gelesen haben